[Music]
first up you may or may not have noticed
that britain is experiencing a labor
shortage there is for instance a lack of
truck drivers available
and a concomitant shortage of produce on
supermarket shelves
is it all bad news though
i'm joined by matthew lin who wrote the
spectator's cover piece this week which
is entitled payday who's afraid of
higher wages as well as andrew adonis
the remain campaigner and the chairman
of european movement
uk
matthew in your cover piece you argue
that despite the obvious disruption it
is a good thing that the labor market is
changing can you run us through your
argument
yeah absolutely i mean you know
obviously you know in the uk at the
moment we're seeing
you know quite severe labor shortages in
a way that we haven't for for a heck of
a long time you're seeing you know
critical shortages of truck drivers
hospitality staff
and you're seeing you know some
shortages in in in the shops some
restaurants closing at lunchtime uh but
you're also saying and this is the
interesting bit is you're also seeing
rapidly rising wages you know we're
seeing um cost of coffee for example you
know gave a five percent pay rise to
what it's stuff i think five percent
it's not going to be enough you know
you're going to get the cost to it in a
couple of weeks time and there won't be
anyone to off the milk for you uh we're
seeing truck drivers getting 20 to 30
percent uh pay rises um so you know i
think the overall picture is is you know
uh fascinating we haven't been in the
situation in the uk uh for a long time
uh but we are seeing you know we're
definitely seeing disruption and and
that's difficult but the free market
works redisruption you know it has price
signals um it has shocks
most of the time those are fairly minor
but sometimes they're quite extreme when
you you know when you get extreme
changes in market conditions you get
quite extreme price movements and we're
seeing that at the moment in the labour
market but you've got to keep sight of
the big picture i think you'll get
through the disruption and we'll take
three to six months or so at the end of
it you'll see you know very significant
rises in blue collar wages that's not
great for everyone you know it's not
great if you're running a big company or
even if you own a small company but if
you're you know if you're one of the
blue collar workers who haven't had a
great deal in the last 20 years um you
know it's hard to see what's exactly so
terrible about the 20 to 30 pay raise
andrew uh matthew suggests that brexit
is just a small part of the picture here
do you think he's guilty of painting a
rose-tinted picture
of the brexit situation and britain's
economy
well he invited us to look at the big
picture and the big picture that he's
painting has some elements i quite like
i mean i love the idea that the
spectator's not going to come out
campaigning for much higher wages i
assume a much higher minimum wage he
talked to 20 to 30 percent higher wages
for blue collar workers well most union
negotiators wouldn't think that that was
uh immediately attainable so if we're
now having a realignment that has a new
center being created where people on the
right who tended to argue in favor of
much lower wages
for manual blue-collar
traditionally unskilled workers there
should be much higher wages for them
then i'm all in favor of that and that's
great and that's alone worth my coming
into the spectator to debate with
matthew on the issue of brexit though of
course you could have much higher wages
and you didn't need to brexit the issue
on brexit is whether you're going to
cause this massive disruption in being
able to recruit anybody to fill these
jobs at the moment because whatever your
view about the medium term and the
median term i'd love to see
higher wages and a new equilibrium of
high wage and higher skill that's great
but the short term we're we're facing at
the moment which you can never discount
because the short terms have an uncanny
habit of going into medium and long
terms as well he says a few months how
does he know it's going to be a few
months before we can start dealing with
this hundred thousand backlog of hgv
drivers that's a hundred thousand out of
six hundred thousand that we had before
the pandemic so dealing with those
short-term issues is also important and
again regardless of your view on brexit
pragmatism is required here what should
obviously have happened was the issuing
of a large number of short-term visas to
enable eu workers who were previously
doing these jobs to do so on the same
terms and to encourage them to do so and
the failure of the government to do that
is straightforward ideological
negligence it was ideological because
they weren't prepared to do it because
of brexit and it was negligent because
as a result we've got empty supermarket
shelves which
massively impede the operation of the
market
so there are some complicated things
going on here but the big thing about
matthew's article i think is absolutely
fantastic which is that the spectator
and people who traditionally been on the
right and wanted more inequality in
society like matthew are now
dramatically in favor of much higher
wages for blue-collar workers and
low-paid workers because they think
somehow that's going to be a brexit
dividend what i want is to continue
trading
profitably with our european partners
not put all these impediments in place
but also have the higher wages and i
think that's absolutely possible i'm not
sure the spectators always campaign for
inequality i'm not sure that's quite
fair but i mean what the point matthew
makes is this is what people voted for
when they voted for brexit do you think
that's a fair point people were fed up
of
an economic system that did not see
their wages grow you say that you can
have
wage growth without brexit but the fact
is there hasn't been
wage growth at the bottom end of the
economy for a very long time well i
think there's a much much bigger problem
underlying the uh the the vote for
brexit in
in in particular the midlands and the
north which was the lack of a proper
economic plan for any sustainable
long-term jobs in many of the
communities that voted heavily for
brexit and a big challenge for us all
and is is how you put that right what is
the economic future
of all those east coast towns and many
of the industrial centers that have been
de-industrialized over the last 30 years
now brexit to my mind is almost
irrelevant to that because brexit isn't
going to produce any new industries or
jobs in these areas
and we've now got to concentrate really
really seriously as a country and what
we do do about it and i suspect that
process isn't even going to start until
we've worked
brexit through the system and it's
probably created even larger levels of
unemployment in its wake matthew i'll
let you reply to what andrew just said
that
uh well i mean and and andrew
made so many attacks there it's a little
it was a little hard to keep up with
them i mean just a couple of points on
that i think you know it's unfair to say
that people on the center right have
campaigned um
in favor of inequality uh or lower wages
i think i think that's just just just
ridiculous you know people are people
probably on the center right or the free
market like we believe in market
outcomes uh but we certainly think it's
great when market outcomes produce as
they should if you allow them to operate
properly and in the correct framework um
higher wages and and hopefully lower
inequality i think just on the brexit
point i mean i don't i don't think we
should make this particularly about
brexit i think one of the problems in
this country is obviously you know we're
still
we're still tending to wage that battle
everyone's still arguing about it and
we're certainly in the aftermath of it
so we kind of look at everything and say
well that's that's good because it's
brexit that's bad because of brexit i
think i i tried to reflect this in the
piece you know this is a global
phenomenon brexit has definitely been a
little part of the story uh in the uk
but we're seeing you know big shortages
of workers in germany last time i
checked germany hadn't left the eu
we're seeing big shortages of workers um
in uh in the united states uh the
mexicans aren't going to the united
states with anything like the same
numbers not illegally i'll put that in
that's that's kind of a caveat but
legally they're not going anything like
the same numbers last time i checked the
united states hadn't left the eu
possibly never even joined it uh so you
know this is actually a global a global
phenomena and you know we can dig into
some of the reasons for that i don't
think we should especially think that
it's a consequence of brexit it's kind
of triggered it and sparked it and
accelerated a little bit i will concede
that but there's a lot more there's a
lot more going there and i think on
andrew's point you know if people like
andrew and i know a lot of the employers
uh are arguing this that if we suddenly
granted a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand extra visas to anyone from
hungary or poland or the ukraine who
wanted to come over here and drive a
truck or clean a hotel room actually two
points on that i don't think they'd come
because they're not going to germany in
the same in in the same numbers that
they were and within the eu germany was
the other country which people moved to
in big numbers as well as the uk
and the germans are critically sure of
workers as well at the head of the
federal employment agency was saying
recently they needed six hundred
thousand more people uh to fill all the
vacancies they have so i don't think
they'd necessarily come and i also think
you know even if they did it would be a
mistake that we've actually started this
rebalancing process which is going to
lead to a a restructuring of the uk
economy uh and it's going to lead to
higher blue collar wages and we've got
you know we we're seeing the disruption
it like any kind of restructuring you
know it is going to be a little bit of
pain involved there's going to be a
little bit of disruption involved just
as when the oil market changes or you
know the corn market changes or the
copper or the copper market changes um
but once you get through that you'll
actually be in a better place so i think
the worst thing we could do is kind of
panic uh you know unless things are
absolutely critical i know there are a
few shortages as long as everything's
roughly working okay we shouldn't panic
we should let the process um
uh pla play itself out i think we'll end
up in a better place so we'll actually
end up with with higher blue collar
wages i believe and and a slightly more
equal leveled up society which i know i
know andrea thinks nobody on the center
right could ever be in favor of that uh
but actually you know actually actually
they are and i think that that will be
an improvement the the great danger i
suppose of
rising wages well we all acknowledge
it's a good thing for wages to go up
even at the spectator we acknowledge
that um is inflation of course which we
saw yesterday i think 3.2 percent is the
cpi
uh rate in august i i mean it is is the
danger here that we will inflate away
any gains uh to wages at the lower end
of the economy thus actually spoiling
any positive effects that that might
have
inflation you know when you have rapidly
rising wages inflation is definitely a
danger but i mean i'm going to make two
points on that it's a it depends on your
pricing power as a company you know if
you're a company and you've suddenly got
to pay 20 more to your staff
um you have the option of increasing
prices and some people will do that i
mean i've known it you know in london
i've noticed you know the price of my
cup of coffee is going up and cough the
coffee industry it was very dependent
upon eu migrant work workforce as we
know and you know some people are going
to put the price of a cup up 20 30 p
and you're probably about to just have
to take that in the chin so you'll see a
little bit of inflation but other other
companies don't have any pricing power
so for example i saw ocado this week was
talking about a 5 million hit to profit
because it has to pay its drivers more i
don't think a cardio can put his prices
up i think you know if they do amazon
will eat their lunch um in a moment if
you're competing with amazon you can't
put your prices up because they'll just
come and destroy you in an instant so
they're going to have to they would say
they're going to have to take that as a
hit on profit so that means you know
there's more money for van drivers for
car day and less money for cardo
shareholders and you know andrew is
going to jump on me and say this is
unusual but i i think that's okay that's
just the market rebalancing shareholders
in a card and the chief executive has a
little bit less money
and the van drivers have a bit more
money that's okay you know that's just
the market working working itself out so
i think we might see some inflation just
one more point on that you know
we are going to see a little bit of
inflation we saw 3.2 percent um this
week that might it might even spike up
to four
but if we're seeing wages i think on the
latest ons figures we're eight percent
across the board uh and we're seeing
definitely in you know things like
amongst lorry drivers
up to thirty percent um uh pay rises
look if you get a thirty percent pay
rise for driving a lorry and prices are
up four percent you still came out ahead
didn't you um so some people are losing
um and uh possibly people at the top of
the top of the pay scale are going to
lose a little bit um but that's just
part of the rebalancing andrew i'll let
you have the last word uh are you guilty
of having a myopic focus on brexit
well i i didn't start with brexit and
i'm not going to finish with it either i
think it's just wonderful that the
spectators now uh miraculously in favor
of of much higher blue-collar wages i
think we should just celebrate this i
hope all the people watching spectator
tv will uh uh will know that now
can you point can you point to any can
you point to any uh
i think that's fantastic so i just want
to applaud the spectator for that
however uh
it is complacent to say that we
shouldn't worry about empty supermarket
shelves massive problems in supply
chains all of those things which
actually are important to the effective
operation of markets which
i thought the spectator also stood for
because this huge disruption we've got
is because a whole basis of trade has
been disrupted and we've contracted our
markets in many ways because we've put
big impediments to trade between
different parts of our markets and when
matthew said that
he didn't think we should offer more
short-term visas to
uh people from other european countries
he wasn't clear on his reason for it
indeed he was contradictory he said that
they wouldn't want to take them up well
if they didn't wouldn't want to take
them up then obviously it's not going to
do any harm but he said ah even if they
did want to take them up it would be bad
now both of those can't be true and the
right thing to do surely is not to
suffer massive disruption not to have
empty supermarket shelves to see that it
is possible for people to take up
short-term visas and short-term work so
we can deal with that but also join the
spectator campaign for a higher minimum
wage higher blue collar uh uh
wages a stronger trade union movement
less uh profits going into dividends and
high executive pay which i also took
matthew to be saying all these are great
causes and i welcome the spectator to
them many years after many of us started
campaigning for them
[Music]
you